what's your favorite wave ways for
monetizing content uh for me right now I
don't think I've ever really monetized
content the way I would like to like
subscription okay so but let me ask you
a question subscription is the best way
to monetize most content but again you
have to plan for that in advance so you
have to say I'm gonna make a
subscription and called the subscription
product called the hustle with with new
ideas and trends every week you've made
by migrate analysts and people are
willing to pay a dollar a month or
whatever ten dollars or whatever it is
and subscription is a great way to
monetize because you're not always
chasing advertisers it's this annuity
that comes in and helps you even survive
in a recessionary environment or like
right now so I love I think
subscription you say whether it's an
online newsletter or an online course or
a subscription community like you know
let's say the trends Facebook community
I think subscriptions my favorite way to
monetize but it doesn't solve the
problem of monetizing when you're not
already in the top one third of content
like like you guys are in by in the top
1/10 of 1% of content you're going to
monetize and do very well no matter what
model you choose whereas the someone who
rakes a newsletter about I don't know
you know some obscure kind of Taekwondo
or whatever they're not going to be able
to monetize a newsletter necessarily
where someone who's going to monetize
how to mow the lawn better is not gonna
be able to monetize but might have one
piece of content that really stands out
[Music]